(message alert)
(dance music)
(sigh)
- Hey man we're gonna grab
lunch at that noodle place,
wanna join?
- No thanks man, I'm cool on noodles.
- Oh, cool.
(dance music)
(message alert)
(phone tone)
- Hey dudes, super
excited, exclamation point.
Going to be a little late,
start without me period.
(phone tone)
(sigh)
(accordion music)
- [Waiter] Are you ready to
order or did you wanna start
with a drink?
- Umm, I'm fine with a water.
- What? No, no, no,
not on my birthday man.
He's having a beer.
- No water's fine.
- Dude get a beer, seriously, I got you,
don't worry about it.
- [Waiter] Domestic beers
are $5 for the next hour.
- Alright, I'll have a beer, thanks.
- My man.
- [Waiter] Thanks for joining
us, have a great night.
(sigh)
- [Danny] Don't worry about it.
- Rough night?
Stop, I'm here to surprise you.
I know you weren't really
looking forward to tonight.
- It was fine, you know, same old.
Not a big deal.
- Okay, well, I have an idea.
It's the greatest one
ever, go with me on this.
We bust out a board game,
we drink a couple beers,
on me, and I just so
happened to have procured
a fabulous movie, that I
think you're gonna love,
because I found it on your DVD shelf.
- I don't know, sounds a little pricey.
- (giggles) stop.
(upbeat music)